payoff diagrams or way of depicting what
an option or set of options or options
combined with other securities are worth
at option expiration and what you do is
you plot it based on the value of the
underlying stock price and I have two
different plots here one that you might
see more in an academic setting or a
textbook and one that you might see more
if you look up payoff diagrams on the
internet or people actually trading
options but they're very similar this
one just worries about the actual value
of the options at expiration this
worries about the profit and loss so
this will incorporate what you paid for
the option this will not this just says
what it is worth so with that said we
have company ABCD trading at $50 per
share and then we have a call option
with a $50 strike price or $50 exercise
price trading at $10 which tells us that
the owner of that option has the right
but not the obligation to buy company
ABCD stock at $50 per share up to
expiration assuming it's an American
option if it was a European option it
would be on expiration so what is the
value of this option at expiration so
this is value at expiration at
expiration so if the stock is worth less
than $50 the owner wouldn't execute it
they wouldn't they wouldn't exercise the
option so the option would be worthless
it would be worthless they would just
let it expire no reason to actually
exercise the option now if the
underlying stock price is worth more
than 50 if it's $51 then you would
exercise it because it's now the option
is worth $1 you can buy something for
$50 and sell it for 51 so it's now worth
$1 if the underlying stock price is $60
of course you would exercise and it's
now worth $10 because you can buy
something for 50 and you could
immediately sell it at 60 we're saying
that the underlying stock price is 60 so
it would be worth 10 and so you have a
payoff diagram that looks something like
this it kind of hockey sticks below 50
it's worthless and then above 50 all of
a sudden it becomes worth something now
if you do it in the profit and loss
model all you have to do is incorporate
what you actually paid for the option so
in this situation below $50 you still
would not
actually exercise your option because
why would you pay $50 for something
that's actually trading for less than
$50 but you would say hey I would have
had to take a $10 loss because I paid
$10 for that option so up until $50 your
profit is negative 10
you have lost $10 you have lost the
price of the option because you wouldn't
exercise it then all of a sudden if the
stock price goes above $50 you would
exercise it but you would still have a
negative profit because you still
haven't made up the price of the option
all the way up until 60 at $60 or
appreciation at $60 per share for the
underlying stock price you could
exercise the option buy the stock at 50
sell it at 60 you would make 10 dollars
doing that but of course you have to
spend $10 on the option so there you are
breakeven but then as you get above a
$60 stock price at maturity then all of
a sudden you start to make money so
these are both legitimate payoff
diagrams for a call option for this call
option right over here they're just
different ways of viewing it this is the
value of the option this incorporates
the actual cost of it